all right let's go ahead and have a look
at five
okay now in your books we really
struggled with this one so i reckon you
should all
draw it some of you got it right but
somewhat by fluke so let's all draw
a little version in your books okay
and with questions that have a diagram
drawing the diagram is often the first
step to knowing what the answer is
so i think we have this kind of shape
you got a right angle there and then you
got some numbers
and i did have to correct that it used
to say 10 okay
now most of you got that you had to at
least add six
four and nine because you're asked to
find the perimeter okay which means the
whole way around that shape
but then that leads the question leaves
the question
what's this um where's my glue gun
seriously there we go here we go um that
leaves the question
well what's this side okay now the
answer is five but the question is how
do you actually get there i didn't
require you to show the working
but the way you get there is pythagoras
now what clue in the diagram tells you
that pythagoras is the way to go
it's the right angle isn't it because
pythagoras is about right angle
triangles
okay so what you can see is that you've
got your four over here
so if you think about this as the
opposite side of the rectangle you've
got four here as well
okay now you have to do a bit of
subtraction here right you've got six
and nine so the difference that is that
little length there
right so that's why it'll be nine minus
six which is just
three that's three
okay now supposing if you couldn't
remember you know that three four
five will give you a right angle
triangle you know suppose you gave this
some name like say x right if you wanted
to and if they asked you to if they
wanted to set it out
you'd say 3 squared plus 4 squared
equals x squared that's pythagoras's
theorem
in this triangle okay so you might even
say
pythagoras is theorem
okay so that's 9 plus 16
i'll just switch them around to the
other side that's 25
so that's why you get x equals five
because we're only interested in
the positive value minus five negative
five is the solution that we don't find
so you you're asking this or this
yeah so i'm thinking of what what's the
number that when i multiply it by itself
square it right what number will when i
do that will give me 25
and the answer is five and alternatively
you go to your calculator
and you could put in the square root
button there
okay and that'll give you that'll also
give you five okay
so once you know that that is five that
was i believe the first mark to get
that distance and then you just add them
up you just add them up
you say the perimeter is six plus four
plus nine
plus five which gave you um
24 whatever units they were
okay see this um this line here
right that's here now the thing is
there's
two answers to this there's not just one
answer there's two
because if i say well what's minus five
negative five squared that's still 25
right so it's like how do i know is it
this one or is it is it 5 or a negative
5.
now the reason why i can know it's it
can't be negative 5
is because i'm talking at a distance
here right sometimes negative five is
meaningful like if i was trying to find
temperature or the location of something
five might mean
to the right and my negative five might
mean to the left
but here i just wanna know how long the
thing is and you can't be negative five
long it's just going to be that one okay
so i meant um
i meant greater than okay